can imagine my frustration when i found
out east texas tech had faculty meetings
that i was not allowed to attend
not that i didn't try goodbye sheldon
darn it
children
[Music]
sorry
i thought you're an irritating young man
who won't leave me alone
that's
rude oh
so how was it did any subcommittees get
formed no show then it was just a budget
meeting ooh budgets do tell most of it
was about reducing the gen ed science
requirement from eight credits to four
but that's less science classes who
would want that apparently the
administration the students and their
parents
did anyone try to stop it no did it
spark a heated debate not really no
were you at least annoyed do i sound
annoyed yes well there you go i can't
believe the faculty is okay with this it
just means students who aren't science
majors need to take one class instead of
two but that's 50 less sheldon this
doesn't affect you less science affects
all of society and in case you haven't
noticed i'm good at making things all
about me yes i have picked up on that
sorry there's nothing i can do about it
i understand you're just a cog in the
machine
in fact why am i talking to you feel
free to stop
[Music]
and do you really want to be the
president of the university that is
responsible for the dumbing down of
scientific discourse on this campus i
totally agree with you
you do oh it's an outrage i came here to
make this school the harvard of east
texas not the dick
what's your least favorite school mit
not the mit of east texas nice dig at
mit well they deserve it so you're gonna
keep the science requirements the same
if it were up to me yes
but you're the president everyone has a
boss sheldon
now unfortunately i have to answer to
the
grand chancellor
oh
i've never heard of him oh well he
definitely
exists perhaps i should speak with him i
appreciate that but
this is my fight win or lose and i'll
probably lose but
i am going to go down swinging i promise
you that
can i help
absolutely i need you to put together a
report backing up our position charts
graphs the whole shebang hmm
twerk some graphs of what
am i helping you or are you helping me
uh of course i'll figure it out i know
you will
okay now get out of here you have a lot
of work to do yes ma'am
[Music]
it makes me thirsty
the chancellor said no did he even look
at my report he did he was impressed but
it didn't change his mind
after all our hard work
i know bummer
but hey we gave it our best shot so time
to move on right absolutely not
are you sure because
it feels like time to me we have to keep
fighting if anthony von luinho had given
up where would we be
where would we be in a world without
microscopes
because that guy invented them boy did
he at least the first modern microscope
he's known as the father of microbiology
i have a good book on him i could loan
you anyway we can't give up
hey you are preaching to the choir but
what can we do i could write to some
science luminaries try to get them on
our side stephen hawking carl sagan not
antony von luwenhoek he's dead but just
done the off chance that they're too
busy to reply
i think that you should get out there on
campus talk to students change their
minds one-on-one
that could take months
great
[Music]
you